qu'en tant que jeune femme on est toutes
concernées par ces faits qui sont d'une
gravité mais sûrement il ya toujours une
certaine omerta autour de ça donc
j'avais vraiment envie que concret un
sorte de mythe ou de la nuit
je m'appelle might be bus j'ai 23 ans et
je suis la fondatrice de la page balance
barre c'est une page qui vise à récolter
les témoignages de femmes qui ont été
droguée au ghb donc par soumission
chimique ou qui ont été agressées
sexuellement ou violées au sein
d'établissements de nuit
[Musique]
il ya eu la sphère des bars du cimetière
d'ixelles ici à bruxelles c'est un
quartier étudiant ou un serveur a été
visée par plusieurs plaintes de femmes
et qui disait avoir été drogué il a donc
été transféré dans un autre café tenu
par le même patron j'habite le quartier
de cimetière d'ixelles donc c'est un
problème qui m'a touché de base j'ai
l'âge d'être étudiante je connais aussi
énormément de personnes touchées par ces
problèmes là et voilà suite à cet
événement qui a créé une indignation
collective j'ai vu pas mal de
témoignages affluent et à d'autres
endroits que j'ai décidé de relayer sur
la page balance tomba
café belga à ixelles j'ai travaillé au
belga en 2016 dès le début j'ai refusé
les avances d'une des personnes du staff
là a débuté le harcèlement moral et
sexuel j'ai essayé d'en parler en
interne de trouver de l'aide mais la
seule réponse que j'ai reçue a été il
faut que tu t'en ailles
je n'ai plus les mots en fête pour
décrire ce que je ressens vraiment
vis-à-vis de ces témoignages et
énormément de compassion pour les femmes
qui ont vécu ça je les trouve
incroyablement forte mais j'ai un
sentiment de colère évidemment quand je
vois combien de témoignages reçoit qui
sont vraiment similaires là c'est un
témoignage d'une personne qui a
travaillé dans cet endroit mais il ya
également des témoignages de énormément
de témoignages de femmes qui ont été
drogués qui ont subi une soumission
chimique donc et qui sont extrêmement
similaires c'était en 2019 j'ai eu un
black out alors que je n'avais presque
pas bu j'ai le souvenir d'un gars avec
moi à l'arrière d'un endroit que je ne
reconnaissais pas je me souviens avoir
bu la moitié de mon verre et puis plus
rien trop noir comme toujours il y avait
un monde pas possible au milieu de ce
monde une femme était littéralement
balancé et a touché par toute une partie
des sommes du bar elle avait le regard
totalement vide il ya toujours une
omerta et puis une banalisation totale
autour des faits
des faits qui se déroulent dans des
établissements nuit on a toujours
responsabiliser les femmes en leur
disant faites attention vauvert fait
attention quand vous sortez comme si la
charge mentale de cette sécurité là
devait toujours retomber sur une femme
ce qui n'est pas normal non plus en tant
que société c'est notre devoir à tous de
prendre ça en charge nous sommes aux
portes nous sommes fiers et féministe et
radical est en colère nous sommes fortes
sommes fiers et féministe et radical est
en colère cette nuit elle est pour vous
cette nuit elle et pour nous on a
aujourd'hui notre cette nike et on
s'arrêtera pas aujourd'hui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ce un secret de polichinelle on connaît
pertinemment des personnes qui sont dans
un milieu de la nuit et qui font des
violences depuis de nombreuses années
voire plus de dix ans donc c'est aussi
pour secouer le secteur de la nuit pour
qu'il décide de prendre des mesures au
sein de leur secteur aujourd'hui tout
aussi nombreuses aujourd'hui il ya
autant de couvertures médiatiques sert
aussi à louer grâce à l'ouverture d'un
compte instagram qui s'appelle balance
tomba maintenant je vais laisser la
parole à maïté qui est la responsable de
cet instinct g
j'aimerais m'adresser à vous qui m'avez
livrer vos témoignages
merci
merci de m'avoir fait confiance
merci de vous être livrés
merci d'avoir été puisé cette force en
vous qui aujourd'hui permettra le champ
alors concrètement déjà il devrait y
avoir une responsabilisation des gérants
et gérante de clubs et de var pour que
ceux ci mettent en place déjà des
formations pour leur personnel par
rapport à la sécurité des femmes dans
leurs lieux dans leur établissement et
ensuite il devrait aussi y avoir au
préalable avant d'engager le personnel
une vérification de leur passé
[Musique]
amman
c'est un problème qui n'est absolument
pas propre et à bruxelles cantonné à la
belgique c'est un problème qui s'étend
vraiment bien au-delà de nos frontières
et s'il bat l'instant par paris demain
soir lyon marseille poitiers sur lowe's
non ça c'est temps on voit que c'est un
phénomène qui est partout et c'est un
phénomène qui gangrène notre société
dont on parle définitivement pas assez
et comme je l'aï dit précédemment
précédemment je pense qu'en tant que
jeune femme on se sent constamment
vulnérables dans un endroit en
établissement nuit on se sent en 60 pas
en sécurité et ne trouve pas ça normal
e
oui
on
balance son barça représente en gros
coup médiatique évidemment mais derrière
ça il y avait les actrices de terrain
qui travaille depuis des années
pour sécuriser le secteur de la nuit qui
travaillent dans les milieux féministes
ou ça donc voilà je pense qu'elle
devrait être aussi invités à table
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]